i want to switch sports with you though
for a second because
not only do you have relationships in
connection with nfl players you did a
fire fighter profile a yada cententi
kumpo uh not that long ago and so i
wanted to get your insight into giannis
again it was about his journey from
greece or whatever and his identity uh
coming to america but that said
just based on what you know and based on
your sense of things having been around
him and got to know him a little bit
where you think his head is at when it
comes to
the super max versus can i really win in
milwaukee a lot of speculation about his
future right now as you know
yeah i think the biggest thing i took
away from the time i spent with giannis
was that loyalty is everything to him
and especially the way he's so
tight-knit with his family um loyalty is
something that he prioritizes
very closely to him to his heart and so
uh seeing these reports of him having
these conversations with buck's owners
and trying to figure out the direction i
i wholeheartedly believe giannis is
going to try with every intention in
mind to try and make it work in
milwaukee and they've got one more year
to try and figure out you know what
they're going to do
at each position how can they help
upgrade the roster they have i think
obviously the most
easiest spot for all of us to figure out
that they need to address is a point
guard position and finding someone that
can be a facilitator that can create for
other people uh that can allow uh you
know giannis not not putting giannis in
that position where he has to dribble
the ball to court uh every other
possession so you know yeah the bucks
the bucks have a a a huge huge huge
issue there to address that i think
giannis will be taking notes on and
i y'all just gonna try and make it work
i wholeheartedly believe that i i
wholeheartedly believe giannis is gonna
try and make it work in milwaukee i
think milwaukee fits him uh very much so
in terms of the city uh small town he's
not a dude that likes attention remember
there was something that was left out in
the piece that we talked about so much
which is discussing the limelight and
the attention that he's getting now that
he's such a great great elite nba player
back-to-back mvp soon to be and all the
attention that comes with that and it's
something that he was just simply not
prepared for because basketball was
outlet to to escape a life of poverty uh
as a first generation uh immigrant in
greece and now in america i think that
was the area which both of us were able
to bond on because i'm a first
generation american as well and just due
to the simple fact that i i come from
that similar understanding of where
look
when you're broke and you come from
section 8 you come from poverty
you're trying to escape that social
economic status you're trying to break
the cycle but no one ever tells you
everything that comes with success and i
think that's what giannis is starting to
realize and recognize and deal with
especially right now when a lot of
people are criticizing him uh for not
just
developing a spot up jumper or having a
a game that's very versatile that can uh
you know match up against guys like
jimmy butler that know how to shut him
down and toughen up against him
to me being someone from dallas i see a
lot of parallels between giannis's
career at dirk dirk nowitzki
someone who had a silky smooth jumper
coming out of the league but as we saw
against matches against the warriors
even the nuggets
there were other two defensively that
were able yeah they were there were
other teams they were able to to take
them off the spots and punk them so dirk
had to develop that low post game and it
took a lot of time for him to do so but
we're seeing a similar trajectory with
someone like giannis where he's in his
mid-20s he's trying to develop this part
of his game but it's just taking time
and i think i don't think he's gonna be
able to solve his shooting problems in
the next year i think it's probably
gonna take another two or three years
for him to have a more consistent jumper
a formidable jumper that can you know
offset it and be another option for his
dominant ability to get to the paint um
and so
i think that's going to be the biggest
key is that will he be patient enough to
recognize
what the bucks are trying to build
around him to stick around in the long
run and sign a supermax there or will he
just want to keep it moving afterwards
and realize like hey i did everything i
could and i think that's going to be the
biggest
uh thing that we all have to watch for
if the bucks are able to make it to the
finals i think giannis will find a way
to try and make this thing work next
season but okay that's easier said than
done man in the eastern conference
finals as we've seen man because celtics
are still really good uh the heat aren't
gonna get any worse either it's gonna be
very very tough